تفتح اله الحرب الاسرائيليه نيران حممها
على قطاع غزه المنهك بالحصار فتتراء ازمه
انسانيه منذره بالاسوا صحيا ومعيشيا
في الواجهه طواقم الدفاع المدني وهي عاجزه
عن الاستجابه لنداءات الاستغاثه الكثيره
فالقصف الاسرائيلي المدمر سوى بالارض عده
مباني وتحت الانقاذ والركام ضحايا يسابق
المسعفون الزمن لانقاذهم لكن هؤلاء الرجال
تعوزهم الوسائل والمعدات اللازمه بسبب
الحصار الطويل على القطاع ولا تنفصل مصاعب
الدفاع المدني عما يواجهه القطاع الطبي
المتهالك اصلا جراء الحصار ايضا فهو يشكو
نقصا في كثير من الادويه والاجهزه ومع
ارتفاع اعداد الشهداء والجرحى يشتد الضغط
على المستشفيات وتزداد حاجتها لتلك
المستلزمات غير ان الاحتلال يمعن في
اجراءاته العقابيه حيث يواصل اغلاق معبري
ايريس بيت حانون وكرم ابو سالم التجاري
بشكل كامل منذ بدء الهجوم على القطاع
الثلاثاء الماضي قد بدا فعليا العد
التنازلي
لايقاف محطه الكهرباء الوحيده المغذيه
للكهرباء في قطاع غزه ما لم يكن هناك تحرك
عاجل
وبالنسبه للامم المتحده فان انقطاع الطاقه
عن غزه يمكن ان يصبح محور الازمه
الانسانيه في القطاع
معابر الاسرائيليه مع غزه مغلقه لليوم
الثالث على التوالي وتستنفذ احتياطات
الوقود بسرعه مما اضطر محطه توليد
الكهرباء في غزه الى تقليص عملها كما يجب
ادخال المواد الحيويه الاخرى الى غزه بما
في ذلك المواد الغذائيه والامدادات الطبيه
فورا
استنادا الى احصاءات المكتب الاعلامي
الحكومي بغزه دمرت الغارات الاسرائيليه
حتى مساء الخميس 19 وحده سكنيه تدميرا
كاملا بينما تعرضت اكثر من 300 وحده سكنيه
لاضرار جزئيه وبينما يكتفي العالم بابداء
الانشغال ازاء ما ترتكبه اسرائيل بحق سكان
قطاع غزه اصدر الاتحاد الاوروبيانا ابدى
فيه القلق مما سماه التصعيد ودعا جميع
الاطراف الى احترام القانون الانساني
الدولي وحمايه ارواح المدنيين وممارسه
اقصى درجات ضبط النفس بينما دعت وزيره
الخارجيه البلجيكيه الى تهدئه فوريه قائله
ان بروكسين تدين العنف وان الهجمات التي
تستهدف المدنيين تنتهك القانون الدولي